how embarrassing how embarrassing
how humiliating how humiliating it's
going to be
brothers and sisters do you guys want to
make money the halal way no it's not a
scam
it's actually buying and selling
products brand new sealed
phones problem sisters and other gadgets
check this thing inshallah and you can
get a direct
link to suppliers obviously at a cost
but you will get a discount just visit
the website or go to this instagram page
message them and you will get discount
how to get connected and start your own
business
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends
how embarrassing how embarrassing
how humiliating how humiliating it's
going to be
all the islamophobes be it from a pus
the little weasel who gets embarrassed
like his happy days
yeah two rotten wood
two dcci
to these guys tommy robinson who just
lost a lawsuit uh and has lost about
600 grand you know sadly you know he had
to probably sell his house on a few
properties that he earned
through this uh money uh organizing a
march how embarrassing is it now
isn't it embarrassing that you jump to
speculations without knowing
and you jump to assumptions and i think
watching this
apus yeah you rotten world david wood
yes you
tommy robinson you'll be watching this
as well and this other guy called danny
roscoe ever told his bloody name is who
i challenged for a debate
and all this slammer fobs how stupid
would you or are you going to be looking
because the person
that you fought was a muslim right
anyway i didn't i don't i don't feel
very well
you jumped to speculations and
assumptions and you made a whole
campaign
you decided to come to the park to do a
march
april's wanted to invite harton sorry i
didn't oh i don't i don't feel very well
david wood making videos everyone
jumping on the bandwagon
how embarrassing isn't it just think
about it for a second brothers and
sisters just think about it for a second
as muslims do we want the perpetrator to
be muslim of course not because that's
not what islam teaches and not only that
we know
that backlash our sisters are going to
get on the road because these cowards
usually attack men you know
um we don't want them to be a muslim the
funny thing
is the ones that are watching this video
like tommy robinson
rotten wood apus pocillanomus weasel
i didn't i don't i don't feel very well
and the rest and all the islamophobes
are gutted watching this video
like jaw dropped like nah
nah now brothers and sisters
this video has a little bit of a twist
now what's this twist
i don't know if the person is a muslim
or not we don't know
we do this actually between that we
don't know yes i know the video said it
is
but the reason i did this video is and
now they can have a bit of fresh air
that fear is enough for them the fact
that you're watching this and all of you
islamophobes
you cowards the fact that you watched
this and clicked it and like
oh my gosh oh my gosh that fear is
enough for you
in turkish and i think one will
understand this
you understand that fear is enough for
you now
we don't know if he's a muslim or not i
only did this just to make a
very important point because if
it's found out because we know before
halton got attacked by another
stupid idiot who was actually a
christian who smacked her
yeah and people were jumping on the
bandwagon did anybody invite hartoon
for an interview did anybody invite her
no did harton press charges
no because it was a christian shh
let it go let it slide let's move on no
interviews need to be done
no religion of peace attacks again no
islam is this or that or the prophet
taught they said this
even with this now there's a bit of a
suspense it's like an england match
isn't it
it's not cool is it a muslim what if
it's not oh that's going to look bad
tommy robinson are you are you going to
be going to cancel the martial speakers
corner if it's not a muslim
what's going to happen are you still not
going to come to the park if this was a
hindu
or let's suppose another christian or
for other personal reasons this person
attacked harton for whatever
argument saying is everyone going to
cancel everything
is the party going to be over yes it is
the tickets i'm not going to be sold
everyone's going to be like oh that was
embarrassing let's move on
that is the point of this video because
everyone is jumping on the speculation
right and i know all of these cows are
having
like they're just like oh my heart just
dropped all of them
why because they want it so badly they
want it so badly
for it to be a muslim and that is the
point of this video
and everyone that's watching this the
islamophobes and the muslims
the muslims don't want it to be a muslim
why because it does nothing but bring
harm
you know so this coward who did this
attack on a defenseless woman she's
defensive no matter how rich she is the
defense is
never a woman yeah he's a coward and i
hope he gets caught
and when he gets caught and if he's not
a muslim i would love
and pay any price to see the face of
these idiots
because you know guys the issue is not
about freedom of speech
the issue is about freedom to attack
islam
only and my gosh isn't it rich coming
from tommy robinson
isn't it rich coming from him to come
and defend freedom of speech
my gosh i'm like me and hijab mohammed
job i'm seeing people who came to your
rally
freedom of speech and you stopped me
from coming in and i was nearly getting
killed
yeah he was nearly getting killed
murdered literally
on the ground yeah you coward it's
you talking about freedom of speech my
gosh it's rich coming from you
you know to pussyland was weasel you as
well you coward you're exposed
the point is this guys that these things
bring nothing but joy and happiness to
the islamophobes the fact that i did
this video they were
bugging albedo panicking when they saw
that they were like no no
no this is the point they are happy like
steve was
muslims that they were not happy except
a few had
silly individuals why because they know
that this is not from our religion and
what is done is wrong no matter how rich
she is yeah
that is our point but the islamophobes
are happy let that sink in
when islamophobes are happy and the
muslims are not that shows you
what the agenda as a whole is and let me
tell you something and i'll end on this
though
yeah i genuinely hope that this coward
uh attacking sends this woman yeah uh
this woman's senses and his senses as
well himself
i hope he gets caught yeah muslim or not
you are not going to stop our daughter
you're not going to stop the shahada
that's coming in
you're not going to stop the spread of
islam and the people hearing the truth
that's not going to stop all that's
happened here is this defensive woman
got attacked which is wrong
yeah and this coward hopefully he gets
done yeah
so in a nutshell i believe haatun
wallahi i believe is from my heart heart
and her likes
aid islam her coming and insulting the
prophet and doing this all this kind of
stuff
she aids islam those who attack her
they are the ones who are making islam
look bad
can you imagine that harton is aided in
islam but those who are attacking
are making islam look bad the point here
is this brother and sisters
let heart on carry on because by her
doing that people that are neutral
see that and say wow this is christ like
this is the jesus you're talking about
i mean can you imagine jesus is love and
mercy he loves his enemies
and all she does is hate to me that does
nothing but aid
islam and i want harton to carry on not
that i like her hearing
insulting the prophet no but i wanted to
carry on so people can see the true face
of such christian militant christians
brothers and sisters
hope this video has made a few pennies
drop
because i'm sure it did and as you can
see the double stands in hypocrisy
our dial will continue till the day we
die
we do not want hate or anyone to be hurt
that's why i've been against isis very
clearly
so even if this person is a muslim or
not muslim we still don't know now
everyone's jumping on a bandwagon yeah
but even if he's a muslim it doesn't
affect us because we know he's free from
our deed
and um that person is free from islam
yes
and even if it's not my gosh i would
love to see your guys faces
brothers and sisters until next time
assalamu alaikum
share this far and wide i think the
point is being made
and i think that little fear that i put
in this thermophobic heart was down
worth it
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi
careto